il n'y a qu'une seule vraie question
jurés vous sur votre vie
que vous dites la vérité
mon père me prédisait une cuillère
heureuse
je me suis marié
j'ai été pas des pouces
puis-je été jugée et milliers pas
[Applaudissements]
je la firme ici devant vous
je n'ai jamais dit que la vérité
[Musique]
la plus épouvantable des accusations a
été formulée contre nous
chaque le gris est entré chez nous
il m'a agressé
l'accusation fausses
je dis la vérité
la vérité n'a aucune importance seul de
pouvoir des hommes comptent
l' affaire doit être réglé dans le cas
je suis innocent
j'aurais que la madrelle judiciaire si
vous perdez votre femme en subira les
graves conséquences
là nous deux a menti laissons dieu en
décider
vous ne me croyez pas
je risque ma vie pour vous et vous
risquer ma vie pour sauver votre
réputation
le châtiment
pour faux témoignage
et le bûcher vous serez
brûlées vives
se refuse de me taire
[Musique]
les voilà dames et messieurs et charmant
futur époux et humilié marque
[Musique]
espèce de salopards tu disais que tu
étais mon meilleur ami qu'est ce que
vous faites ici
[Rires]
j'ai désolé c'est un événement privé
d'accord aux écoulons que nous les
mariés on a rencontré ces deux belles
four au mexique
le sel n'a pas toute seule je croyais
avoir été clair quand je vous ai dit
elles font bien leur boulot ça n'a rien
de clair vous nous avez drogué je
croisais aux drogues même pas en
vacances
écoutez on essaie de les contenir
pourquoi tu leur as dit à bientôt ça
laisse la porte ouverte et ils sont
passés je voulais pousser tous pourtant
cela n'empêche matière mais j'espère que
tu aimes les parties à quatre jackpots
des combats quelque part
c'est le chaos
tout le week-end il n'y a que vous qui
comptait jeunes qui a compté 10 heures à
windham et messieurs qui centre marcus
et moi on s'est croisé au mexique et ma
pièce que notre bâtiment c'est le
meilleur mariage auquel j'ai jamais
assisté mais ces bouteilles sur ta tête
y plaisons bébé le blanc est la
bouteille c'est pas juste
[Musique]
seigneur nous vous rendons grâces du
nous rassembler autour de cette table
nous mettrons de la joie dans chaque
pièce ab
j'ai fait monter des jouets dans sa
chambre j'espère qu'il se plaira ici
et qui sont ces étranges personnages
avec leurs capuches j'en sais rien elle
m'a rien dit
la demeure que vous habitez a été bâtie
sur des ruines de quoi parlez vous vous
entendez des choses la nuit c'est à
propos des voix
quels risques ils monsieur leloup trois
heures
quelle heure est-il monsieur leloup une
heure
quel rythme
a dit
hadi
et cette pièce alors elle était
interdite cette messe - quelque chose de
bizarre cette maison dressent les
enfants entre leurs parents les marées
contre leurs femmes pouvez vous m'aider
dieu vous a vendu votre fille il peut
aussi vous la reprendre
quand les ténèbres se rapprocheront et
qu'à part la peur ne ressentirez rien
saurez-vous encore qui poussait
pourquoi dieu de l'ertms il l'existence
du mal
[Musique]
à m'en suis la
télé doit pas vu d'autres continuent
pour moi j'ai vendu le quoi en gros on
est tous un peu d'argent et on vend des
choses vous voulez quoi
parler elle est le maintien et leur dure
les affaires vintage qui ne m'était
jamais non mais ça va pas toucher mais
d'après joseph aviez souhaité chaussures
pendant les troubles
josette a pas touchées mais m
non mais je vous êtes fait quoi ça était
belle ses démons d'une élection c'est
combien avoir fait sa famille et lui 150
mais pour faire quoi ils viennent pour
faire quoi pour sauver la planète a pas
[Musique]
j'ai que vous faites là c'est pour la
télé
[Musique]
écoutez apparemment c'est pour sauver la
planète ah ok d'accord
[Musique]
c'est quoi cette idée en fait on va
faire une très très grande mais en
afrique
c'est bien des enfants au projet
vous étiez au congrès rire du tout
[Musique]
tout ça j'ai bien réfléchi mois
si tout ça c'est vraiment sérieux leurs
projets
je ne serai pas là puisque partout tout
seul tu partir avec lui tu rigoles
[Musique]
demande si t'es pas jaloux docly de
notre fils son courage je te remercie
t'as rien
quand j'achète les poubelles et les
couleurs différentes rien de triste ou
fascine ont
piégé près les ampoules qui consomment
moins aussi c'est bien
[Musique]
j'aurais dû prendre mes raquettes
pourquoi les gens remettent ce qui est
très marrant c'est que bien que ce soit
des traditions ça reste l'un des moyens
les plus efficaces de marché sur la
balançoire je crois que vous allez vous
plaira biver field
[Musique]
chaque personne qui vit à quelque chose
d'un peu suspect un jeune prêtre contre
les habitants
et le mauvais temps
c'est la totale
[Musique]
or
on leur faisait en fait une tête on
dirait que vous avez vu un cadavre les
routes sont en piteux état nous avons un
problème avec le générateur qu'elle
générateur ils sont tous en panne
j'arrive pas à aller sur internet
juillet on est aussi un cadavre sous le
porche
c'est probablement un loup est devenu un
spécialiste des loups marcus allez
savoir où et quand il remettra ça et qui
sera sa prochaine victime
je crois qu'on est tous d'accord pour
dire que le danger rita l'extérieur
qu'il convient de rester groupé simple
colis ce n'est qu'ils portent une arme
alors c'est parti pour la soirée pyjama
avec des flingues avec des flags les
méthodes de ce prédateur sont très
singulière ce n'est pas un humain ce
n'est pas un canidé mais c'est l'un
d'entre eux ce serait quoi alicante rock
quoi altran 7h louga
il y aurait pu entrer
il est sorti plus tôt
avis qu'il était sorti
c'est peut-être moi le loup garou
c'est peut-être toile de garantie
tm garde
damien
quand on est tous des loups garous
c'est quoi le topo on se retrouve dans
une impasse mexicaine rougerie ont dit
aux mexicaines c'est une impasse tout
court
elle est sûrement déjà ouvertes
logiquement elle devrai il suffit de
vous essayer de sortir sa marque ne veut
par ce système de sécurité qui veut
plaire
j'aurais très bien pu arriver ça
[Musique]